all right thousand college best ayodhya
Oh a box in the middle of the carpet
well that should be an adventure
I think I know where we need to go we
solved that hey I'm gonna throw you
while I talk is that okay is that okay
[ __ ] odd sherbet okay well it's gonna
have it that way I'm not gonna well I
was talking about something yeah we all
like the elevator thing and cats a share
and we need to go I did not cheat by the
way changing is for that I just broke my
legs but that's okay there we go we need
to go down here I've not cheated
anything beyond this okay how am i sir
how am I supposed to know I'm gonna go
stop looking at me with those judge
flies that's beautiful sexy touch for
lies I was pretty gay okay I got a ton
of my volume there we go
all right uh-huh
pop that is normal
oh and we're [ __ ] don't stray from
torches well thank you pan I'll keep
going with you oh this is this is
[ __ ] creepy
oh [ __ ] me in the [ __ ] okay can we go
ahead I do not like that okay that's
looking fun that is the next one
hello there doc darkness is for [ __ ]
tense is for badass
gob Han Terauchi shadow match don't
worry about it oh hey nice meeting you
wow I wish we met sooner but a [ __ ]
someone didn't get their breakfast today
oh wow okay my method that was easy
right that was easy right
we did it you don't even pee your pants
B problem I would applaud it but after
that become I must not surrender myself
the division of that hopeless life there
is meaning in faith as in what I can
escape Lulu I can save me my mind has
become weak but I know who can save me
I know I have my doubts about already to
be completely honest I don't know about
that man
okay where are we in the garden thing
alright the door wasn't locked after all
I guess am I losing my mind here
yeah it's Oprah here Oprah someone told
where is Oprah
where is she where is I have oh prep
hair spa you're not nearly as beautiful
what are you what are you doing stop
following me
get the [ __ ] outta here alright so now
we can go down the elevator it's not
lovely we waited a long time to go for
it down the elevator right Oprah yes
pads that's gonna be awesome
oh I'm glad you're excited oh I'm
excited alright you're gonna [ __ ] die
what was that
nothing pears I'm Oprah okay well let's
go and party this is a very unnerving
sound alright sorry about that Oprah
it's like a felony ah there it is
oh snap I finally get it
finally I got to spin the wheel yes
how's it it's not an elevator
well I'll pry your comment with me
either way all right ow
haha well that's nice Oprah okay
everything parodies salvation
the final horror before my awakening
opera do you know anything about dad yes
I didn't know nothing okay good I trust
you Oprah I think I have this cake yeah
you hear that Oprah is [ __ ] um don't
really feel like reading that
okay let me see if we got some goodies
no nothing really really that's fine I
don't care
can I go home
I don't brag we're going to the
monastery
sometimes my grasp upon this reality
awakens and I find myself slipping into
another world you ever feel like that
bras like you Shh
no that's me actually I don't feel it
either so I guess it doesn't make sense
to anything so how was your night go on
you think I should just play and set up
okay I'll do that that's a lot of
[ __ ] shirt
how you doing that I know you had
somebody's siblings position whoa
well okay this is pretty damn
beautifully designed I have to say oh
I'm sorry and I I didn't know you were
down there we go there you go and back
to your friends have fun Thank You
Pierre Tyler whatever you don't need to
go in the love is the love word I have a
really nostalgic feeling about this
place
it's kind of weird what the [ __ ] did I
just do what the [ __ ] that I just don't
let me do it again
what did I do a demon sacrifice hi only
ty didn't mean a touch it oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh god what the [ __ ] am i doing ah
it burns my hand every time should I'd
really do this Rose should I
ah Yolo am i right
now out
all the shares are very angry now now
did I miss that I miss some of them that
what I wanted what in the heavens okay
in the name of simple mechanic and
Emerson I'll solve that with a crowbar
how is this locked [ __ ]
shares tell me what to do don't [ __ ]
with me shares I'll [ __ ] ride you
it's like surfing yeah
sharing the USA dead at a time at a
table at no wait that's the wrong theme
song while [ __ ] they didn't tell me I
had to sacrifice my what did I miss
then I do it in the wrong order
there's nothing behind it what is in
that room Oh shed
I gotta lift all these candles just for
dramatic effect now this one more
at that in their shed
what other why you scare me you [ __ ]
this is so unnerving I do not like this
I really don't [ __ ] like this
shut up shares my pants were on your
side oh god fly fly fly fly flatware
black I don't know what to do
shut up shares oh just shut up for a
second
thank God ah what what the [ __ ] what the
Virginia's cold that's good in here
how's it going guys how's everyone doing
Omar sacrificed a [ __ ] Yolo I shot
meth I stuck it was me alone here you
want to ride into my trap but another
one okay let it out out go away rip out
sorry okay
that was that it was that it hi guys
oh look at that I did I'd look at that
Wow
what oh oh whoa oh whoa oh no no no what
what did not what I didn't do anything I
like
uh-oh uh-oh
hi I didn't sign up for this [ __ ] hi I'm
out I'm out it was a shower I saw you
now light no light but well what are you
doing what do you do it no no no no no
no no oh whoa whoa well now we calm down
a little bit I think someone needs to
reconsider what the [ __ ] there go ahead
stop that [ __ ] okay Yolo mode
Oh Oh do not like this I do not either
ah
now
oh oh oh I know I know I go in here bad
idea
very bad very bad what do I know what is
it I don't want to play this anymore
only items can deter the tada
well [ __ ] me in the ass